à de nouveaux partenariats public privé
mr fous les applications la morale
d'état monsieur olivier marc l'ex oui
madame la ministre de l'éducation
nationale il ya deux ans vous avez
procédé à une refonte de la carte de
l'éducation prioritaire qui était sans
doute nécessaire mais qui a laissé en
suspens jusque là le cas des lycées pour
lesquelles vous avez entretenu un
certain flou mais tout récemment dans un
courrier à notre collègue sébastien
pietrasanta vous avez semblé acter que
l'éducation prioritaire ne concernerait
désormais plus les lycées cette annonce
suscite de très vives inquiétudes chez
les enseignants mais aussi chez les
parents d'élèves et les lycéens
eux-mêmes
en effet la disparition complète de
l'éducation prioritaire est
catastrophique pour ces lycées c'est
moins de moyens pour les établissements
scolaires avec des dotations horaires
qui ont d'ailleurs commencé à diminuer
et c'est la fin pour les enseignants à
la fois d'un système de prix mais aussi
de bonification qui ont permis de
stabiliser de fidéliser le corps
enseignant dans ces établissements de
manière extrêmement sensible et très
positive pourtant vous le savez
l'éducation prioritaire au lycée a porté
ses fruits avec moins d'élèves par
classe la possibilité de proposer des
options des sorties scolaires des
projets très stimulant pour les élèves
au bout du compte une meilleure réussite
aux examens
comme le disent avec beaucoup de fierté
les enseignants de nos lycées notamment
à dreux dans ma circonscription dans nos
lycées l'ascenseur social fonctionne
c'est une phrase qui fait du bien à
entendre madame le ministre
alors pourquoi mettre en péril un
système qui marche
à l'heure où les jeunes ont des jeunes
dans le quartier notamment ont tant
besoin de l'école de la république
madame le ministre
les enseignants des lycées de zep ont le
sentiment que finalement ce sont leurs
lycées les plus fragiles qui vont payer
l'addition des promesses parfois
inconséquente qui ont été faites depuis
il vous demande donc de vous saisir
avant la fin de ce quinquennat puisqu'il
vous reste cinq mois de ce sujet et
attendent aujourd'hui que vous les
assuriez de l'avenir de leur lycée ils
attendent des actes la parole est à
madame najat vallaud belkacem mini the
education nationale de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
marc l'ex c'est une très agréable
surprise pour moi que de vous entendre
soutenir avec autant d'emphase
l'éducation prioritaire et la réforme
donc que nous avons conduite en faveur
des écoles et des collèges dans un
premier temps comme nous l'avons fait et
qui a permis en effet d'avoir désormais
une carte plus socialement juste et des
moyens d'action beaucoup plus efficace
avec je le rappelle un effort budgétaire
de près d'un demi milliard d'euros pour
l'éducation prioritaire alors vous dit
une chose qui est juste c'est que notre
réforme de 2014 a concerné les écoles et
les collèges qu'elle n'a pas encore
concerné les lycées qui seront à leur
tour réforme et bien sûr durant le
prochain quinquennat que nous
effectuerons j'en viens à votre question
s'agissant des lycées actuellement en
éducation vous plaît s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît assurez les personnels
qui exercent en attendant cette réforme
bien entendu les moyens dédiés à ces
établissements sont entièrement maintenu
à la prochaine rentrée je les en est
d'ailleurs déjà informé et j'ai décidé
par décret et d'augmenter de maintenir
pardon pour deux années supplémentaires
les indemnités liées au statut
d'éducation prioritaire des personnels
de ces lycées d'éducation prioritaire
par ailleurs un arrêté qui est paru
jeudi dernier pour la mobilité des
enseignants du second degré prévoit que
les établissements les lycées qui
jusqu'à présent n'était pas en éducation
prioritaire mais qui présente des
caractéristiques proches c'est à dire ce
qu'on appelle établissements en
affectation prioritaire à valoriser à pv
bénéficieront également d'une
bonification à la rentrée 2010 est et
que ceux qui étaient concernés par ce
type de mesure déjà par le passé en
bénéficieront également pour leurs
mouvements de 2018 2019 je pense qu on
vous disons que l'éducation prioritaire
ça n'est pas seulement la réforme de
2014 c'est aussi ce qui est entrée en
vigueur à cette rentrée les parcours
d'excellence qui permettent désormais à
des élèves de la classe de 3e jusqu'à la
grèce de terminale d'être accompagné tu
te